he's got a rifle he's on the right folks
out fire shots fired two Wisconsin
police officers are shot and killed
after pulling over a suspect wanted for
missing child support payments officials
now calling him the epitome of evil
ready are you good okay we're a project
all right it's on his left
the Wisconsin Department of Justice
released dozens of photos and videos to
lawn crime Network showing what led up
to the deadly shooting on April 8th it
happened in Barron County about two
hours East of Minneapolis Chetek police
officer Emily breidenbach and Cameron
police officer hunter shield pulled over
an SUV driven by 50-year-old Glenn
Douglas Perry Perry was armed with a
rifle both officers are down he set up
with a rifle
327 we have two officers two officers
down he is set up with a rifle prior to
the shooting officials say Perry was
displaying concerning Behavior after a
messy divorce in an interview post
shooting Perry's ex-wife told officials
she believed he was bipolar and
schizophrenic she also noted he had
multiple guns in an interview with
detectives Perry's son said he quote
talks pretty bad about cops his son also
noted Perry quote trains to kill them
more or less with a gun range built on
his property
[Music]
just days before the shooting on March
30th a civil bench warrant was issued
for Perry after he went months without
paying child support just one day before
the shooting the Barron County Sheriff
sent out a warning email about Perry's
concerning behavior and mental health
issues the email instructed Law
Enforcement Officers to use quote
Extreme Caution if approaching Perry as
he garried a handgun at all times
according to a report by the Barron
County district attorney 32-year-old
officer Emily breidenbach stopped
Perry's vehicle on April 8th during a
routine Patrol shift breidenbach did not
immediately pull him over because of the
recent warning email instead she called
for backup 23 year old officer hunter
shield responded Shield's body camera
footage shows the first moments of the
traffic stop
the Barron County DA's report states
that breidenbach called out commands to
Perry after she pulled him over nearly
immediately he grabbed an AR-15 and
began firing he's got a rifle Sapphire
shots fired
officer down officer down officer down
Shield can be heard putting out a shots
fired call before his body camera video
shows him falling to the ground
all right
after this a call for backup comes out
across radio traffic
[Music]
a 9-1-1 call also comes in from a
witness nearby 911 where is your
emergency
hi I'm I'm actually just
sitting here um I ended up pulling over
because I saw
a dog in the middle of the road and then
all of a sudden I see an officer down in
a gentleman on the ground looks like
he's waiting on his leg and a rifle on
the ground as well
quickly a call goes out for emergency
responders
Sheriff Department
requested Highway eight double last
Highway double s
for an officer-involved shooting time is
15 39.
104 recovery we have EMS page I will be
sending a chopper
[Music]
both officers are down he's set up with
a rifle some of the first officers to
arrive work to secure the scene calling
for onlookers to leave immediately
get out of here
get out of here go
video then shows officers arriving to
the scene of the shooting requesting all
detectives please requesting all
Detectives
temper hey are you doing okay we're a
project
yeah we see it all right zone is left
all right I got I got
I got the
uh move the gun I got a lethal yep I got
lethal cover me I got guns radio chatter
notes the suspect may be wounded I
believe the subject is down I believe
the subject is down there's three
subjects down officers on the scene
confirm that 331 bear and I do not have
eyes on the subject at this time
iron four
I believe this subject is down I believe
the subject is down there's three
subjects down Jess
yeah
is he down
he's down
at the same time officers distance
Perry's weapon from him and call for
more First Responders get this rifle
nope I got lethal
you got that yep
okay roll them
we got two offices down we got 195.
He's the bad guy is also shot
hold on clear it I got it I got it
no no back's clear front's clear that's
good got another rifle up front
according to the DA's report breidenbach
fired Two Shots before Perry fatally
shot her she'll also fired his weapon
but also was shot and killed by Perry
officials say Perry was shot in the leg
he later died at the hospital per the
Barron County District Attorney's final
report both breidenbach and shield were
justified in their deadly use of force
the report also states that Perry
obtained all the weapons used in the
shooting and later recovered in his
vehicle and at his home legally
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie